[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu unter
den linden spezial noch drei wochen bis
zum wahlabend anfangs lagen bündnis
90/die grünen mai vorn in den umfragen
jetzt sind sie auf platz drei wie die
grünen auf die wahl blicken und mit
welchen ideen sie die menschen
überzeugen wollen darüber spreche ich
jetzt mit der fraktionsvorsitzenden von
bündnis 90 die grünen im bundestag
frau katrin göring eckardt herzlich
willkommen guten tag ja wie erklären sie
sich dass die grünen gerade nur noch bei
16 prozent in den umfragen stehen und
quasi genau die umgekehrte entwicklung
zur spd gemacht haben naja bei nur noch
ich war ja beim letzten mal
spitzenkandidatin also wir mit 8,9
rausgekommen insofern ist es erstmal
nach wie vor ein großer vertrauensbeweis
ein großer zuwachs und in der tat ist es
ja jetzt so dass wir sehen das
jedenfalls olaf scholz nach vorne rückt
armin laschet nach hinten wir werden die
letzten wochen zu kämpfen haben das
werden wir auch tun weil die frage um
die es jetzt geht ist haben wir am ende
eine klimaschutz regierung ja oder nein
und das wird daran hängen wie viel grün
da drin ist und ob wir die regierung
anführen können und auch darum kämpfen
wir nach wie vor ist es gerade olaf
scholz den die menschen mehr vertrauen
schenken als annalena baerbock ich
glaube dass es ehrlich gesagt die große
veränderungen anstehen das weiß
inzwischen jede und jeder und die frage
ist ja wie viel vertrauen kann man haben
daran dass diese veränderungen auch
gestaltet werden man kann sie über sich
kommen lassen das haben wir die letzten
jahre erlebt ich habe ja schon einige
erfahrungen politische ich habe auch
einige erfahrungen mit denen die viele
erfahrungen haben wie olaf scholz zum
beispiel und da wurde immer vorher viel
versprochen am ende wenig gehalten von
dem was man vorher gesagt hat und die
letzten jahre sprechen nicht unbedingt
dafür dass urlaub chance dafür steht
dass die veränderungen gestaltet werden
die getan werden müssen sondern sie
kommen immer und dann versucht man zu
reparieren diesen unterschied müssen wir
machen und ich glaube dass das sehr
viele unternehmensführer gerade sind ja
meistens männer nach wie vor gesagt
haben sie trauern an der dna der burg am
ehesten diesen aufbruch diese
veränderungen zu die jetzt notwendig ist
um die man neutralität und
wirtschaftlichen erfolg und damit eben
auch soziale gerechtigkeit zu erreichen
da würde ich sagen das ist erstmal die
eine gute perspektive und das wird es zu
verbreiten gelten und darum werden wir
auch kämpfen das klar zu machen sind hat
die erfahrung schon angesprochene
erfahrung ist natürlich ein vorteil in
vielen dingen nach den fehlern bei
lebenslauf und beim buch der wirkte
annalena baerbock doch verunsichert und
erst beim tri l wieder kämpferischer ist
es genau diese fehlende
regierungserfahrung und vielleicht auch
die fehlende erfahrung mit massiven
gegenwind die dann doch ein bisschen zum
problem wurde da sie stellt sich dem
gegenwind jedenfalls und sieht macht
auch klar ich habe meine position ich
habe meine haltung auch und sagt dann im
zweifel auch ein interview ab und dann
entsteht entsteht eine leere seite wie
bild am sonntag ich fasse also ich meine
die frage was jetzt mal für prioritäten
und sie hat andere prioritäten gesetzt
sowohl in den medien als auch bei der
frage wo bin ich eigentlich also bin ich
jetzt nur in berlin oder bin ich lieber
draußen im land ist ja nicht so dass ihr
gesagt ich gebe niemals diesem medium
ein interview hat sie auch schon gemacht
aber jetzt in dieser phase eben nicht
ich fand es richtig und erfahrung ist
natürlich ein hohes gut auf der einen
seite auf der anderen seite führt bei
manchen erfahrungen dazu und das erlebe
ich jedenfalls bei den mitbewerbern dass
es nach dem motto geht das haben wir
immer schon so gemacht und wir sind in
der phase bei der klimakrise aber auch
beim auseinanderdriften der gesellschaft
dass wir nicht mehr sagen können das
haben wir immer schon so gemacht und
deswegen ist der frische blick auch mal
zu sagen nee lass es uns nochmal anders
machen nochmal neu überlegen noch mal
anders drauf schauen der ist glaube ich
in dieser phase in der wir jetzt gerade
gesellschaftlich politisch in der
wirklichkeit sind sehr elementar anders
so sieht es zumindest jetzt aus würde es
werden man ist ja auch eine
dreier-koalition raus zu laufen was wäre
denn ihr favorit welche koalition wir
immer nicht wünsch dir was und dann sagt
man vorher was man gerne hätte vor
derweil kämpft man immer darum dass ja
die eigene partei die meisten stimmen
bekommt und möglichst möglichst viele
dass es der stand in den rest sind man
wird sagen natürlich wenn es am ende
reichen würde für rot und grün dann wäre
das eine koalition wohl sehr viele
übereinstimmungen sind glücklicherweise
und wo es aber dann auch auf die frage
kommt wie sind die kräfteverhältnisse
und ob meine klima regierung hat oder
nicht das hängt genau an dieser frage
und das ist der elementare neue punkt um
den es gehen muss und wenn es nicht
reicht für rot grün wenn es nicht dafür
reicht dann werden verhandlungen
schwierig werden und die werden auch bei
rot und grün schwierig werden muss man
sich nichts vormachen aber dann wären
sie noch schwieriger werden sagen wir
also so und dann schauen wir uns an wo
man wie viel erreichen kann sie kommen
aus thüringen dort regieren die grünen
mit der linkspartei ist die linke aus
ihrer sicht im bund regierungsfähig ja
sie hat sich ja gerade mit der
afghanistan abstimmung neulich als es
darum ging menschen dort herauszuholen
ziemlich ins abseits gestellt und die
linke muss selber entscheiden ob sie
regierungsfähig sein will oder nicht ich
sehe das aktuell nicht sondern da gibt
es widerstreitende interessen und das
müssen die untereinander klären und
insofern ist das jetzt nicht meine
aufgabe ist aber natürlich eine frage
die die wählen denn gerade umtreibt weil
man natürlich bevor man sein kreuz macht
doch wissen will was kommt denn am ende
möglicherweise raus deswegen noch mal
nachgefragt bei der abstimmung haben
sich die linken mehrheitlich enthalten
glauben sie dass die partei es schafft
so wirklich die realpolitischen
erfordernisse zu sehen und die ideologie
ein stück weit hinten anzustellen also
man auf nummer sicher gehen will dann
macht man das kreuz bleibt sondern sich
die grünen sie gesagt man will ja vorher
wissen und ich kann das schwer
einschätzen ich also in thüringen
erleben wir das ja da haben wir eine
linkspartei die zuverlässig ist wo man
weiß da stehen auch alle in der fraktion
wenn es darauf ankommt und dann kann man
regieren und kann gut regieren das ist
aber im bund eben anders und es wird
wahrscheinlich in der neuen fraktion
dann auch noch mal anders sein ich kenne
es nicht alle die da kandidieren oder
aussichtsreich sind in den bundestag zu
kommen aber die frage ist stehen denn
auch wirklich alle und ist die
perspektive klar also ist die
perspektive klar für eine solide
außenpolitik für eine solide
finanzpolitik für eine gerechtigkeit
politik die mit klimaschutz die mit
wirtschaftlichem erfolg zusammen passen
und diese fragen die kann nur die
linkspartei selbst beantworten klein war
für den moment noch mal kurz bei
afghanistan die regierung in thüringen
wollte er mit einem eigenen landes
aufnahmeprogramm afghanen ermöglichen
nach thüringen zu kommen aus humanitären
gründen das bundesinnenministerium hat
da jetzt ein riegel vorgeschoben
die situation in afghanistan können wir
nicht national lösen so die
argumentation sondern nur europäisch
überzeugt sie das ich finde es absurd
und ich finde ehrlich das ist auch
zynisch also in der situation wo die
bundesregierung selbst daran schuld ist
so muss man es wirklich formulieren dass
so viele menschen nicht nach deutschland
nach europa geholt werden konnten dann
hinterher zu sagen das muss man jetzt
mal europäische ist und von sich selber
weg zu schieben dass das hat wirklich
komische züge ich sag mal warum ich
glaube dass die bundesregierung das
nicht vorher gemacht hat war ja klar
dass so etwas passieren würde es war
nicht allen klar wie schnell aber wenn
man die leute eher raus geholt hätte
hätte man ja vielleicht den diskussionen
bei uns gehabt über die frage was ist
mit geflüchteten was ist zum beispiel
mit familiennachzug viele die hier sind
also die jetzt schon hier sind auch
schon länger hier sind die fragen sich
natürlich was ist mit unseren familien
angehörigen in afghanistan
die sind genauso gefährdet wie die
ortskräfte einfach weil ihre verwandten
in deutschland sind und dann nicht zu
sagen
nachdem sie so viel angst davor hatten
es könnte eine diskussion über
geflüchtete geben nicht jetzt wenigstens
zusagen aus menschlichen humanitären
erwägungen ist es unsere verdammte
pflicht die durchaus zu holen das finde
ich wirklich absurd auch nach dem zum
beispiel eben thüringen gesagt wir
nehmen die auf
gleichzeitig ist es ja so dass jetzt man
erfahren hat am wochenende das
straftäter zurück nach deutschland
gelangt sind und wohl auch ein gefährder
wie schafft man es denn dass man der
humanitären verantwortung gerecht wird
aber trotzdem verhindert dass jetzt in
diesem chaos solche menschen wieder
zurück nach deutschland den weg finden
das sagt mir dass man selbst angerichtet
also wir unser vorschlag war ja schon
seit 2009 sehen visa auszustellen für
ortskräfte um genau solche dinge zu
vermeiden und jetzt muss man natürlich
kontrollieren wer ist dass es kommt ja
offensichtlich auch raus und dann muss
man sehen wie man die sicherheit
gewährleistet das ist übrigens auch
schon vorher so gewesen dass wir
straftäter abgeschoben haben die dann
auf anderem weg wieder zurückgekommen
sind manchmal auch mit einem anderen
namen und man fragt sich dann wären die
nicht in einem gefängnis in deutschland
sicherer aufgehoben auch für alle
beteiligten aber diese diese kontrolle
diese gefährdung vor augen zu haben das
ist jetzt einen job den natürlich die
bundesregierung machen muss und alle
sicherheitsorgane vor ort oder hier oder
beides sowohl als auch ich meine im
moment kommt ja kaum noch jemand da
überhaupt raus und es gilt natürlich für
beides aber man kann jetzt auch nicht
sagen man lässt die leute einfach alle
dort in der sorge dass man wegen des
chaos' man selber angerichtet hat dann
leute mit hierher holt die als
straftäter bekannt waren sondern man
muss man dafür sorgen dass die natürlich
erkannt werden und dann entsprechend
gehandelt werden muss damit die
sicherheit nicht gefährdet ist in
deutschland dann blicken wir mal auf die
klimapolitik die flut hat ja gezeigt
dass die auswirkungen uns ganz konkret
alle betreffenden das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat
wirklich denkt kampf gegen den
klimawandel ja nochmal roten wind
gegebenfalls fünf user ohnehin
dennoch hat man den eindruck dass die
grünen dieses momentum noch nicht
richtig nutzen können woran liegt das
aus ihrer sicht mehr was wir nicht
wollten ist tatsächlich sozusagen mit
einem transparent und für kaputte häuser
und straßen zu stellen das macht keinen
sinn trotzdem hat man gespürt
dass die auswirkungen der klimakrise im
aartal in new york wenn man sich die
brände in kanada anschaut wenn man sich
anschaut wie die situation in italia so
mitten in europa ist die brände dort auf
der insel euböa ich bin dann mal im
urlaub gewesen und wenn ich mir das
anschaue dann blutet mir das herz
genauso wie bei dem was viele menschen
verloren haben und was ich was ich
jedenfalls spüren ja viel in deutschland
jetzt auch gerade unterwegs ist das ein
klar ist das hängt miteinander zusammen
das ist nicht jedes einzelne extreme
wetterereignisse gab es ja auch schon
mal welche aber dass es so viele sind
dass sie so kurz nacheinander sind und
dass man sich dann immer die frage
stellt wer hat denn die klimakrise
auswirkungen auf uns ja hat sie sehr
konkret und ob unser wohlstand gefährdet
ist ja oder nein das hängt davon ab ob
wir jetzt jedenfalls stoppen was ein
weiterer erderwärmung abzusehen ist und
ob wir es hinkriegen dass in den griff
zu bekommen sowohl mit maßnahmen die
klimaanpassung sind also dann muss man
sich gedanken darüber machen wie
organisiert man die städte anders welche
dämme baut man und sofort und auf der
anderen seite wirklich alles dafür zu
tun dass die erderwärmung gestoppt wird
damit wir selbst aber natürlich erst
recht die kommenden generationen noch
die chance haben wie das
verfassungsgericht gesagt hat in
freiheit zu leben weil es geht um die
freiheitsrechte das ist ja eine
begründung des verfassungsgerichts
urteils die ich mir nicht hätte träumen
lassen aber genau das ist der kern der
frage
noch profitieren die grünen trotz all
dieser entwicklung profitieren die
grünen zumindest jetzt wenn man die
umfragen betrachtet noch nicht richtig
von dieser entwicklung trifft da
beispielsweise jemand wieso mit seinem
video er nerv bei den jüngeren zb ja ich
glaube dass das dass das auch klar macht
wo es hingeht haben sich auch viele
künstlerinnen und künstler
intellektuelle gerade dafür
ausgesprochen bündnis 90 die grünen zu
wählen aus gutem grund und und das
risiko mit seinem video gemacht hat ist
natürlich für diese klientel
aufklärerisch und ich habe es mir selbst
auch angeschaut und und denke ja so also
klar zu sagen was ist eigentlich
passiert was es nicht passiert wer ist
involviert wäre es eben nicht involviert
das zeigt im grunde genommen sehr genau
dass die große koalition in den letzten
jahren sich immer nur auf den kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner geeinigt hat und das
können wir nicht mehr machen wir müssen
wirklich das große bild im blick haben
wir müssen haben wir müssen klar haben
was es bedeutet in städten zu leben wo
es laut und dreckig ist wir müssen klar
haben was es für gesundheit bedeutet
also alle haben immer das gefühl werden
gerne heile welt und dann steht man da
und sieht die welt ist an so vielen
stellen nicht in ordnung und wir haben
hierzu tote werden leute die darunter
leiden wir wissen dass bestimmte
krankheiten mit der hitze zu tun haben
wären auf der anderen seite die
überschwemmungen von denen wir gerade
schon gesprochen haben und wenn man wenn
man das reparieren will wenn man will
dass es besser wird wenn man will dass
wohlstand erhalten wird dass wir unsere
existenz auf dieser erde nicht gefährden
und erst recht nicht für unsere kinder
oder meine enkel oder sowas dann muss
man jetzt wirklich beherzt klar handeln
und man kann ich mir hin und her gehen
man muss klar sagen was sind die
maßnahmen die dazu führen dass es
verbessern lassen sonst genau über die
maßnahmen jetzt mal reden was sind die
konkreten maßnahmen die sie ganz direkt
ergreifen wollen würden wenn sie denn in
regierungsverantwortung kommen also ich
hab dann muss man muss wirklich ein
klimaschutz sofortprogramm machen und da
müssen einige sachen drin sein die die
weichen tatsächlich stellen zum beispiel
haben wir ja nach wie vor in bayern oder
in nordrhein westfalen so pauschale
zwangs abstände für windräder jetzt
sagen alle wir brauchen mehr windkraft
es geht hoch wenn man ist auch macht und
das ist ein beispiel dafür das zweite
wir müssen solaranlagen unsere dächer
bringen auf alle neuen auf alle
sanierten dächer auch auf kirchendächern
zum beispiel oder denkmäler wo man sich
gedanken machen muss wie geht das
zusammen
da kommt dann auch mal ein bisschen
stress auf aber kann man muss man machen
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass jetzt klar
wird früher raus aus der kohle wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass wir die
gebäudesanierung in den blick nehmen
dass ein viertel ungefähr der co2
einsparung die wir brauchen ist im
gebäude also im gesamten gebäudebestand
das macht man auch nicht innerhalb von
drei tagen aber jetzt planungssicherheit
zu schaffen dass handwerkerinnen und
handwerker das unternehmen die
investieren wollen wissen ja das ist der
plan da ist das geld dafür das wird auch
bereitgestellt und deswegen sind wir
auch teil davon deswegen während der
arbeitsplätze geschaffen deswegen können
wir so planen damit kann man sogar geld
verdienen aber ich glaube darauf kommt
es an dass wir sofort solche maßnahmen
ergreifen die den hebel umlegen damit es
in die richtige richtung gehen was den
menschen angst macht dabei ist dass das
also wenn man jetzt beispielsweise sagt
solardächer aufkirchen das wirkt zwar
sehr konkret man ahnt aber die
diskussion die dann losgehen tauf und
auch für den ganz normalen menschen wie
soll das so organisiert werden dass der
einzelne trotzdem nicht in hohen kosten
erstickt die ja angesichts von inflation
sowieso gerade schon recht hoch sind ich
verstehe die sorge sehr gut und deswegen
haben wir uns auch darüber gedanken
gemacht wie kriegt man das hin dass man
weiß klimaschutz und soziale
gerechtigkeit gehören zusammen ich hab
schon über die gesundheit geredet ja
eine extrem soziale frage weil sind ja
die ärmeren die da am meisten darunter
leiden also die irgendwie an den großen
straßen muss besonders laut und
besonders warm ist zum beispiel wohnen
müssen aber es geht natürlich auch um
sehr konkreten sozialen ausgleich
einerseits durch den bürger energie geld
wo wir sagen das was co2 steuer
zusätzlich ist geben wir eins zu eins
zurück und zwar pro person vom säugling
bis zur großmutter und dann ist auch
klar das bedeutet man kann dafür sorgen
dass es sich lohnt was einzusparen und
man weiß die leute mit der kleinen
wohnung dem kleinen portemonnaie dem
kleineren auto und nicht fünf mal im
jahr nach malle fliegen die werden am
ende des jahres sogar ein plus auf dem
konto haben aber es geht auch um mehr
also wenn wir haben im letzten halben
jahr mehr ölheizungen in deutschland
eingebaut und nicht weniger ist ja
absurd das ist eine kostenfalle für die
leute die in diesen häusern wohnen also
egal ob das jetzt einfamilienhäuser sind
oder mietwohnungen da dafür zu sorgen
dass es sich auch für handwerkerinnen
und handwerker lohnt wir zu sagen nee
wir fahren jetzt mit den neuen heizung
an die auf erneuerbare energien setzen
darauf kommt es an also ich finde alle
diejenigen und das führe häufig auch von
den anderen parteien design also
soziales oder klimaschutz oder man müsse
das in balance bringen man muss beides
machen und es muss ich eben beides für
die bürgerinnen und bürger auch im
wahrsten sinn des wortes auszahlen
konnte schon einige punkte angesprochen
dass energie geld oder auch prämien für
handwerker oder auch in der diskussion
zuschuss für lastenräder ihr
wahlprogramm wird an der stelle
konkreter mitunter als bei der
konkurrenz allerdings dadurch natürlich
auch kleinteiliger und ein bisschen
lässt es erahnen dass es auch
wahrscheinlich mehr bürokratie braucht
wie wollen sie das machen dass man nicht
bürokratie aufbaut um diese kleinteilige
förderung hier eine prämie da eine
prämie die muss ja irgendwie so zu
organisieren sein dass es nicht noch
mehr bürokratie die wie soll das
funktioniert weniger es muss einfacher
werden und alle diese fragen müssen
einfach wir haben uns natürlich gedanken
darüber gemacht wie geht es so dass es
sich für alle lohnen das für alle
machbar ist also für die einen in der
stadt ist natürlich das lastenrad für
die leute auf dem land manchmal auch
aber die brauchen andere dinge brauchen
andere angebote den ordentlichen
nahverkehr zum beispiel der zuverlässig
ist und alle stunde fährt und ja die
werden auch als pendlerinnen und pendler
noch weiteren zuschuss brauchen auch
mehr geld dafür dass er sich dann später
meine auto kaufen können ich würde nicht
sagen dass das kleinteilig ist sondern
die ids gesamtkonzept die idee ist wir
schauen uns die lebenssituation den
alltag der unterschiedlichen menschen an
ob das die studentin ist die in der
stadt lebt oder ob das die pendlerin ist
die auf dem land lebt oder ob das die
bäuerin ist die zur zuhause irgendwie
hin und her fahren muss und dann aber
auch in die stadt will um dort bestimmte
dinge zu erledigen also
alltagssituationen anschauen und weniger
bürokratie heißt für mich wenn ich was
beantragen will dann gebe ich nicht noch
fünf mal dieselben angaben an die
verwaltung
sondern mache ich das noch einmal und
dann muss die verwaltung sehen die sie
dafür sorgt dass das funktioniert und
ich glaube das ist etwas wo wir viel
darüber nachdenken müssen wie man
hinbekommt dass die verwaltungsvorgänge
einfacher werden natürlich digital aber
das irgendwie auch klar als diese ganze
antrag zu bereiten schluss haben also
also die verwaltung ist ja gerade jetzt
nicht unterfordert wie wollen sie das
machen dass dann diese unterschiedlichen
prämien organisiert werden können dass
das finde ich jetzt gar nicht das ist
gar nicht so schwierig weil es ja klar
wenn es ein fördergeld gibt also es gibt
ja schon lastenrad förderung in
deutschland in sehr vielen bundesländern
nicht nur in den modi kuren regieren die
sind immer ganz schnell weg weil das ein
relativ einfache antrag ist und dann
macht man den dabei der e-autos
beispielsweise der e auto prämien ist es
auch nicht so schwierig die wird
beantragt und dann kriegt man die und
dann helfen die verkäufer auch noch mit
beim bürger energie geld ist es ganz
genauso also man kann das über
verschiedene tools auszahlen ob das am
ende die steuer ist oder ob es die
krankenversicherung ist die
rentenversicherung vor allem übrigens
auch für die leute die grundsicherung
bekommen die müssen das aufs konto
kriegen und zwar anfang des jahres und
das das ist nur eine frage des wollens
und wie man es am besten umsetzen kann
und da soll sich dann leute auch darüber
beugen die sagen man nimmt dieses oder
diese oder jene möglichkeit aber wir
sind wirklich in einem land wo man
ständig irgendwelche anträge stellen
muss um das zu bekommen was einem
eigentlich zusteht ich werde euch noch
einen ganz anderen ich würde es umdrehen
wohin drehen ich mit einem ganz anderen
beispiel das geld für kinder ja also die
einen kriegen das als steuerfreibetrag
das sind diejenigen die mehr steuern
zahlen und besser verdienen die anderen
müssen für alles einzeln anträge stellen
ich möchte dass wir nicht nur eine
kindergrundsicherung haben die für alle
auskömmlich ist sondern dass sie
automatisch aufs konto kommt wenn ich
sehe wie viele leute die ärmer sind
alleinerziehend sind dann immer noch
ständig einen neuen antrag für alles
mögliche stellen müssen und zuschüsse
dann sagt hier ein hört bitte auf damit
gebt den kindern das geld die kriegen
der steuer-id wenn sie geboren werden
dann können sie ja auch das geld
überwiesen bekommen steuern ist das
nächste stichwort all diese maßnahmen
müssen finanziert werden
da wollen die grünen auch die
vermögenssteuer wieder erheben und
tatsächlich auch kleine entlasten
reichere belasten
wohl konkret unterscheidet sich der
grüne planen von dem plane spd als geht
es gar nicht so sehr darum wo
unterscheidet sich das sondern was ist
das angebot also ich finde in der tat
eine vermögenssteuer ist deswegen
richtig und gut weil das ein steuer ist
die bleibt in den ländern da hat jetzt
der bund gar nichts dafür davon sondern
die blatt in den ländern und wir wissen
wir brauchen mehr geld für bildung
definitiv und damit können die länder
auch neue investitionen in bildung
gewährleisten aber es geht natürlich
auch insgesamt darum wie will man das
ganze bezahlen und deswegen sagen wir
man kann mir schwarze null wie so ein
heiligenschein um den kopf machen wenn
unsere kinder oder enkel und sein eines
tages fragen was habt ihr eigentlich
damals gemacht anfang der 2020er jahre
dann möchte ich nicht sagen müssen wir
hatten einen ausgeglichenen haushalt und
das war generationengerechtigkeit wir
konnten dann leiter das mit der
klimakrise und was mit der
bildungsmisere nicht gewährleisten nicht
bewältigen dann wäre das wirklich die
falsche antwort deswegen schuldenbremse
ja das braucht man für die
generationengerechtigkeit aber mit einer
investitions klausel für die
transformation kosten die wir jetzt
haben damit wir überhaupt
generationengerecht sein können und
wirtschaftsinstitute finanzinstitut
haben auch ausgerechnet dass sich das am
ende auch zurückzahlen lässt ganz
einfach weil das natürlich investitionen
sind die auch gewinne bringen die das
bruttosozialprodukt anheben investition
in bildung klingt immerhin gut
allerdings ist es ja so dass mitunter
gelder gar nicht so das problem sind
sondern eher die tatsache dass sie nicht
abgerufen werden wie wollen sie denn da
dran gehen weil eine investitions regel
wurde das problem ja noch nicht lösen
sondern wurde erst mal nur ein stück
weit natürlich schon dazu verleiten dass
man sagt man kann da noch mehr geld erst
mal
ja sozusagen in umlauf bringen aber noch
nicht an den kern gehen dass diese
gelder gar nicht abgerufen werden ja der
kern davon ist ja das ist das immer
kompliziert ist also ich mach mal zwei
beispiel wir haben digital parkschule da
haben eine verfassungsänderung dafür
gemacht die verhandlungen waren ewig
lang und schwierig und jetzt ist es geld
da und es wurde zum beispiel nicht
abgerufen und das haben wir dann während
der pandemie wirklich schmerzlich
gespürt warum weil die regeln dafür sehr
kompliziert waren und weil man nicht
vorgesorgt hatte und dann hat man
gesehen meine güte da ist zwar geld
dafür die software aber nicht mehr dafür
dass er auch noch jemand ist der dass
einrichtet und dann waren hing das
wieder an die lehrerinnen und lehrern
und wenn eine schule jemanden hat der
witwer hat es gut funktioniert bei einer
anderen schule nicht also einfachheit
ist wirklich das a und o auch wenn es um
sowas geht wie das weiß ich sportstätten
sanierung da gibt's dann immer projekte
des bundes dann laufen die wieder aus
dann fragt man sich natürlich daher
wollen wir das jetzt beantragen können
wir hinterher die unterhaltungskosten
für irgendwas gewährleisten ja oder nein
deswegen sagen wir eine engere
zusammenarbeit zwischen bund und ländern
in der bildung wenn es um kita geht auch
wenn es um grundschule geht wir reden
jetzt ja hoffentlich über das ganze
programm und hoffentlich wird es auch
jetzt durchgesetzt werden können aber da
gibt es noch mehr ich finde bildung ist
eine nationale aufgabe und deswegen muss
es eine engere eine einfachere
zusammenarbeit geben die luftfilter sind
noch so ein anderes beispiel es hat über
ein jahr gedauert also im juni 2021
stand endlich das geld bereit vom bund
für die luftfilter dann rufen mich
natürlich elternvertreter ansagen wie
sollen wir denn das jetzt noch
hinkriegen und schulen sagen und sagt ja
keiner ob die dinge jetzt wirklich bei
uns genau wirken dass es auch wieder
wirklich bürokratisch total überfrachtet
dazu sagen hier macht es einfach ihr
habt wahrscheinlich ein unternehmen in
eurer nähe überlegt mit denen gemeinsam
was geht und das geld steht dann
unbürokratisch zur verfügung das die
dinger fehlen heißt jetzt dass kinder
weiter gefährdet sind am alten
schuljahres
ich würde gerne noch bei der
vermögenssteuer bleiben weil auch das
ist ein instrument wo man erst mal sagen
kann gerade nach der pandemie
da müssen jetzt in einflussreichen die
reichen mehr zur kasse gebeten werden
kritiker sagen aber dass genau das und
instrument ist was erstmal viel
bürokratie auslösen wird dann ist ja
auch juristisch nicht ganz einfach das
so aufzusetzen dass es wirklich bestand
hat und es gibt kritiker die sagen das
wird so viel aufwand auslösen der sich
durch den ertrag gar nicht rechtfertigt
was entgegnen sie dem meer das wird
nicht einfach sein die vermögens-
feststellung wir wollen ja auch dass
leute die investieren in die unternehmen
kann ich sagen auf der einen seite
wollen wir dass ihr co2 neutral wert und
investiert und euch was dafür überlegt
und auf der anderen seite nehmen wir
euch das gleiche geld weg das soll nicht
so sein also eine vermögens feststellung
wird nicht einfach sein man hat sie dann
aber auch man muss das dann ja nicht
jedes mal wieder neu machen sondern man
hat eine gute grundlage geschaffen und
dann geht das auch mir geht's übrigens
nicht darum dass ich sage die einen
sollen bestraft werden sondern es gibt
einfach darum dass alle sich beteiligen
und dass wir diese investitionen in
bildung wo mir viele unternehmen sagen
wir brauchen die unbedingt das sind ja
nicht nur die eltern sind ja nicht nur
die lehrerinnen und lehrer sind ja die
schülerin und schuhe sind auch die
unternehmen die wirtschaft gesagt wir
müssen mehr in bildung investieren und
dann heißt das halt gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung aber wie sieht das
jetzt genau organisieren wollen dass das
trotzdem in einem rahmen steht und nicht
zusätzlich erfordernisse das wird nicht
zusätzlich also es wird nicht nicht mehr
geld kosten als es dann bringt oder das
ja so ein bisschen der fünf im gegenteil
es so zu sein dass man eine gewisse zeit
braucht wahrscheinlich ungefähren ja um
die vermögen festzustellen zu können und
dann kann man auch einfach diese
verluste erheben es geht ja wirklich nur
um leute die als einzelpersonen mehr als
zwei millionen haben also die gruppe ist
schon persönlich so groß und dann muss
man und das wieder die verfassung auch
zu recht vor der gleichheit herstellen
und eben dafür sorgen dass investitionen
trotzdem möglich sind ich glaube dass es
geht und ich glaube dass es eine
anstrengung auch wert ist es
hinzubekommen und diese anstrengung
heißt nicht es geht um mehr bürokratie
sondern es geht natürlich um mehr
gerechtigkeit und dafür zu sorgen dass
es mit der bildung in zukunft besser
funktioniert gerechtigkeit ist ja auch
ein punkt beisteuern generell jetzt ist
es so dass wir in baden württemberg der
finanzminister der grüne dieses online
portal ins leben gerufen hat wo man
steuerhinterziehung melden kann es wurde
dann als steuer stasi bezeichnet wie
stehen sie zu der liebe und ist das
etwas wo sie sagen das ist ein weg wenn
sie an regierungsbeteiligungen hätten
die tatsächlich aus ihrer sicht sinnvoll
ist er ist nämlich etwas weil sie es
genannt haben zu dem wort stasi sagen
ich bin in der ddr aufgewachsen und all
diejenigen die stasi opfer sind die
müssen sich verhöhnt fühlen angesichts
dessen was da behauptet wird und ich
kann nur allen empfehlen gerne harter
streit in der sache aber nicht mit so
einem begriff die opfer der
staatssicherheit die zum teil ihr leben
gelassen haben zum teil ihre gesundheit
gelassen haben die ja viel zukunft
überhaupt nicht erleben konnten weil sie
im gefängnis saßen und und und damit
zugleich zu setzen dass das eine das
andere ist gemein dass gibt es schon in
allen bundesländern das wird heute per
telefon oder fax gemacht und dass man
jetzt sagt das machen wir auch online
ich weiß jetzt nicht was daran die große
revolution ist ein bin ehrlich gesagt
ein bisschen erstaunt darüber ich bin
auch erstaunt darüber dass man so tut
als ob das denunziantentum wäre ich
meine dass man steuern bezahlt dafür
dass unsere straßen dass unsere schienen
dass unsere schulen dass die
öffentlichen institutionen funktionieren
das ist irgendwie eine gemeinschaftliche
aufgabe und das die einen das
selbstverständlich machen sehr
regelmäßig und völlig klar und dass die
anderen versuchen sich da irgendwie
versuchen irgendwie auszubüxen und dass
man dann sagt hey wir wollen aber diese
gerechtigkeit herstellen da ehrlich ich
kann nicht der dumme sein oder die
ehrliche nicht die dumme sein ich
verstehe ehrlich gesagt das problem
nicht so ganz dann kommt zum schluss zum
problem was sie eben auch schon
angesprochen lanckorona pandemie die
grünen den kurs der grupo weitesgehend
mitgetragen jetzt haben sie gegen die
verlängerung der epidemischen notlage
gestimmt warum er wir sind ja jetzt in
der phase wo klar ist man man kann das
mit anderen mitteln lösen und deswegen
ist diese art von dieser schweren
grundrechtseingriff kommen und vor allen
dingen die großen möglichkeiten für den
gesundheitsminister einzugreifen nicht
mehr gerechtfertigt das ist völlig klar
also wirklich team vorsicht ich glaube
was man jetzt machen muss erstens wir
brauchen einen kokon um die kinder und
da drumherum wir hatten vorhin schon
über die luftfilter gesprochen die
leider immer noch nicht da sind aber
alles zu tun was die sicherheit der
kinder die sich nicht impfen lassen
können gewährleistet und zwei sie sind
tun was sie tun er also erst mal klar
machen es muss auch an schulen weiter
getestet werden und zwar mit einfachen
tests und wissen wolltest das ist kein
problem also solltest beispielsweise
auch an weiterführenden schulen an allen
schulen wo kinder unter zwölf sind die
sich nicht impfen lassen können das muss
das muss ja die priorität haben das ist
ja der der entscheidende punkt weiter
dafür zu sorgen dass das umfeld geimpft
ist ist der zweite zentrale punkt und
der dritte ist das alles was man an
maßnahmen machen kann man kann ja noch
diese filter einbauen dann kann
irgendwie für lüftungskonzept et cetera
sorgen das gehört für mich auch dazu so
und das andere ist wir haben eine
bundesregierung die es nicht geschafft
hat dafür zu sorgen dass genügend leute
geimpft werden ich weiß dass manche
sagen das hängt ja an den einzelnen ich
sage nein an wie vielen supermärkten hab
ich eigentlich gesehen dass dann im team
stetig bisher noch nicht und ich gehe
regelmäßig einkaufen an welcher ecke
stehen die leute eigentlich wo ist die
große impfkampagne also ich erlebe das
zivilgesellschaft sich darum kümmert und
zum impfen auf ruft künstlerinnen und
künstler oder bei mir zu hause in weimar
gibt es den kampagne die heißt impfen
stadt schimpfen finde ich hat leute
angesprochen die bisher nicht darauf kam
wie schafft dass die schicht arbeiterin
der schichtarbeiter das alles ist nicht
gemacht wir haben keine 3g regelung also
ist klar ist man muss entweder getestet
genesen oder geimpft seien auch in der
arbeitswelt und wir erleben dass es
einfach alles so weiter geht und es ist
das was wir die ganze zeit schon spüren
wir könnten eigentlich ein herbst der
freiheit der normalität haben und werden
die bundesregierung das nicht
hinbekommen hat die grundlagen dafür zu
schaffen ich finde das ist ein versagen
sie merken ich reg mich ein bisschen
sehr auf 8 ist wirklich ein versagen was
ich null verstehe und das auf dem rücken
sehr sehr viele menschen ausgetragen
wird und besonders derjenigen die es
nicht einfach haben und deswegen ganz
klar das muss ich sehr sehr schnell
ändern letzte frage es ist ja noch nicht
klar wer angela merkel beerbt aber es
wird auf jeden fall jemand aus
westdeutschland sein und stand jetzt er
einen mann braucht es aus ihrer sicht an
der spitze des staates dann jemand eine
frau aus ostdeutschland beispielsweise
als bundespräsidentin darüber wird ja
auch zu reden sein aber erst danach dann
und jetzt machen erstmal bundestagswahl
und ich bin sicher dass die frage was
spielt ostdeutschland für eine rolle
auch bei den verhandlungen und bei dem
was dann in der regierung passiert dass
das ein ganz entscheidender punkt sein
wird vielen dank ihnen für die
diskussionen vielen dank ihnen fürs zu
sehen morgen folgt dann der blick auf
das programm der cdu meine kollegin
michaela kolster hat den
unions-fraktionsvorsitzenden ralph
brinkhaus zu gast es aus berlin
[Musik]